الاستخبارات الامريكيه اكاذب زيلينسكي
ستنتهي بالاطاحه بنظامه وخلعه
سنسحق اعدائنا وستحقق روسيا السلام
بشروطها ودعم امريكي سخري بل المالي
والاسلحه الثقيله
البولنديون وجنونهم ويتخذون خطوه صارمه
على الحدود واوكرانيا تعلن كل ما يحركه
الروس ذهابا وايابا في البحر الاسود هدفا
عسكريا
والاكواس تحشد للتدخل عسكريا في النيجر
والانقلاب يعلن حكومته الجديده ويغلق
المعابر الجزائر تعلن حاله التاهب فالى
اين المفر وجيش بكين السيبراني يخترق شبكه
دفاع اهم حالف لامريكا في اسيا جده تفشل
في انقاذك جمع غفير من الدول تجتمع تتشاور
تطرح الحلول تحاول التدخل وكل ذلك على ارض
السعوديه وبين جماهيرها انتهت القمه بلا
غالب ولا مغلوب لكن مع وعد باعاده
الاجتماع بعد سته اشهر
ليعلن رئيس مكتب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
ان الدول المشاركه في اجتماع جدا لم تتمكن
من الاتفاق على كافه بنود خطه السلام التي
تقدم بها الرئيس فلودي ايضا فما الذي
اتفقتم عليه يا هذا هل عدت من جده بخفي
حنين لكن واشنطن لا تخفي تفاؤلها بت
لك القوه تلك
المرحه المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه
بان واشنطن ستعمل بنشاط على دعوه الدول
الاخرى للسعي في مسار حل الازمه
الاوكرانيه على اساس احترام سياده وسلامه
اراضي اوكرانيا هل اصبحت امريكا تبحث عن
من يقود الوساطه في ازمه اوكرانيا ام انه
مجرد تصريح عابر لتاتي الاجابه الامريكيه
على شكل حزمه دعم عسكري جديد اذ افادت
وسائل اعلام غربيه ان الولايات المتحده
ستعلن عن حزمه مساعدات عسكريه جديده لصالح
اوكرانيا بقيمه 200 مليون دولار لتؤكد
وكاله رايترز بان الحزمه ستشمل انظمه
الصواريخ المضاده للدبابات بما في ذلك تاو
وجافلام ومعدات ازاله الالغام والذخيره
لانظمه الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات وليس
ذلك فحسب فقد صرح رئيس قسم المشتريات
واللوجيسيات في الجيش الامريكي دوجلاس بوش
بان الاداره تعمل على حزمه مساعدات جديده
لاوكرانيا حيث من المقرر عرضها على
الكونجرس في الخارف المقبل وكما يقول
المصريون
زغرتي يا انشراح اللي جاي زي اللي راح
تنتهي حزمه لتبدا اخرى وما من جديد وها هي
شبكه سي ان ان تتحدث نقلا عن
وزاره
الدفعه الاولى من دبابات
الى اوكرانيا خلال نهايه الاسبوع الماضي
وهنا تقول موسكو للغرب
اللي بعده غير ان الجديد هذه المره هو ما
صرح به المحلل السابق بوكاله المخابرات
الامريكيه
والذي رجح ان تنتهي اكذب الرئيس الاوكراني
فلادي مرزيلنسكي حول قدره جيشه على مواجهه
روسيا بالاطاحه بنظامه وخلعه وها نحن
نتصفح المصدر امامكم في الموقع الرسمي
للحكومه الروسيه ليخرج نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ديمتري مدفداف مؤكد بان
روسيا لديها القوه الكافيه لتحقيق جميع
اهداف العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا كما
فعلت منذ 15 عاما بمواجهه العدوان الجورجي
مضيفا سنسحق اعداءنا وستحقق روسيا السلامه
بشروطها النصر لنا والى الميدان في
اوكرانيا حيث تنشر صواريخ اسكندر الروسيه
في مدينه بوركو شرقيه اوكرانيا وتخلف
عشرات القتلى والجرحى ووفقا لوزاره
الداخليه الاوكرانيه فقد سقط اثر الهجوم
سبعه قتله واصيب سبعه وستون اخرون
وكالعاده فاعداد الضحايا تاتي كما هي
موضحه امامكم في المصدر هذا القصف
الصاروخي الذي استهدف مدينه باكروسك مساء
امس هناك تسجيل ل 88 مصابا جراء هذا القصف
الصاروخي مع استقرار عدد القتلى عند حد
عند سبعه قتلى يعني اكثر من نصف المصابين
هم من المدنيين ليؤكد الجيش الروسي تقدم
قواته نحو ثلاثه كيلومترات باتجاه
كوبيانسك التي استعادت اوكرانيا السيطره
عليها في سبتمبر الماضي وليس ذلك فحسب بل
ان حكم مقاطعه خراكم بالتالي كانتشياف قد
صرح بان الجيش الروسي تمكن خلال الايام
الاخيره من تحرير 5 بلدات في المق واصبحت
الان تحت سيطره القوات الروسيه لتزداد
المعارك اشتعالا يا ساده في المقابل قال
الجيش الاوكراني انه قتل عددا كبيرا من
القوات الروسيه ودمر مركز قياده في مقاطعه
خراسون ياتي هذا في ظل توقعات بان يشهد
البحر الاسود مزيدا من تبادل الضربات بين
الطرفين خاصه مع واعيد الرئيس الاوكراني
بان تصبح روسيا دوله بلا سفن حال استمرت
في حربها ضد بلاده وبعد الحوادث
والاستهدافات الاوكرانيه الاخيره لسفن
الروسيه في البحر الاسود صعدت تهديداتها
حيث هدد مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني اوليج
اوستيانكو بان كل ما يحركه الروس ذهبا
وايابا في البحر الاسود بات هدفا عسكريا
موضحا ان هذا القرار اتى انتقاما من
انسحاب موسكو من اتفاقيه الحبوب التي
توسطت فيها الامم المتحده وراعتها تركيا
قبل اشهر على ذكر تلك الاتفاقيه صرح
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب بان اعاده العمل
بمبادره البحر الاسود لتصدير الحبوب
مرتبطه بتنفيذ الغرب لتعهداته مؤكدا ان
بلاده تسعى لحل الخلافات القائمه عبر
الحوار
انتقل الى الجاره البولنديه وبعد ان نفذت
بيلاروسيا تدريبات عسكريه واسعه قرب حدود
بولندا
باشراف جنود مجموعه فاجنا لتثير مخاوف
وارسو مجددا اعلنت وكاله باب البولنديه ان
حرس الحدود البولندي طلب من وزاره الدفاع
نشره الف جنديا اضافيا على الحدود
البولنديه البيلاروسيه واوضحت الوكاله ان
حرس الحدود البولندي اكد ان ما لا يقل عن
19 الف شخص حاولوا بالفعل عبور الحدود
بطول 250 ميلا خلال العام الجاري ما يمثل
ارتفاعا من 16 الف شخص تم تسجيلهم عام
الاحداث والتطورات وفقا لاضاعه ار اف اي
الفرنسيه فان رؤساء اركان مجموعه ايكوس
خططوا لحشد قوه عسكريه قوامها 25 الف
عسكريا للتدخل المحتمل في النيجر معظمها
سياتي من نيجيريا من جهته اعلن المجلس
العسكري عن تعيين الوزير الاسبق علي
الامين زين رئيسا للوزراء في البلاد واصدر
رئيس المجلس العسكري عدد من المراسم
الاخرى بشان التعيينه في مختلف المناصب
بما فيها المفتش العام للجيش وقوات الدرك
والمستشار العسكري للرئيس وقائد الحرس
الرئاسي فيما كان الانقلاب قد اعلن اغلاق
المعابر والمنافذ للنيجر برا وبحرا وجوا
وحتى اشعار اخر بينما افادت وسائل الاعلام
بان المجلس العسكري في النيجر رفض استقبال
وفد ايكواس في ظل الظروف الحاليه
لاعتبارات امنيه وهناك رد خط واشنطن ليعلن
وزير الخارجيه
هي السبيل الافضل لحل الازمه التي سببها
الانقلاب في النيجر فهل ينفي بذلك اي تدخل
عسكري ام ان بلينكن يذر الرماد على العيون
وعلى ذات الصعيد قال رئيس اركان الجيش
الوطني الشعبي الجزائري الفريق اول السعيد
شنقريحه انهم مستعدون لمواجهه اي خطر يمس
بان الجزائر مهما كان نوعه وحجمه وذلك
حفاظا على وديعه الشهداء وضمانا لمستقبل
الاجيال القادمه وفي ذلك اشاره لاي تدخل
على النيجر الدوله المحاذيه للجزائر بحسب
صحيفه واشنطن بوست فقد كان الجواسيس من
الجيش الصيني قد شقوا طريقهم الى داخل
انظمه الكمبيوتر الاكثر حساسيه في اليابان
وكان المتسللون يتمتعون بوصول عميق ومستمر
ويبدو انهم كانوا يسعون وراء اي شيء
يمكنهم الحصول عليه مثل الخطط والقدرات
وتقييمات اوجه القصور العسكريه يا ترى ما
الذي حصل عليه اصحاب العيون الضيقه
[موسيقى]